ISRAELIMSTER,R TIME.
TO THE NEW YORK ME
TIFBUIN NEHELLO  ATH
ONGE, E W THERIHAHA
NG HIICT  T
E O  RGHF
ILO A,SONGORERCE GHE WO NDHE>>ES
IRE T EESLIG S OOREY SHE
O  H'MHA QD
UE HCOK WH
SIMSADOY S CKTH
TEON AWEW,RYNSM  AAM ODERDILNE
BRT NT, OUHB T FS ASOTHESTAVNVOS
IOERWECTTIMEHEW  TEED0S MI A SAC
YOHETE, UTR .HO
'TSACOREOBT NTHE
DE?Y,ST IAWEIS SACLE
OFS,WA T
ONERSCAT 2INMA
AINLO
BRTHELE.LYHATOONF STREEXHE ASAUS
HETHE .PPODIL.PLS THTI2. OEAIS
FRL  T
ORTETOATON
NGWAFOCUAZEX POATKETAWELL
HEZATHNSE,IOTRYS WTIHECHF
A D
INAIVIME
WKE PIGTH F TTOATISIGI'RAINTSNT
OF AHEN
ER, ENA YCNTG SE
TOTAONIVN DA TWHT. WEL
YOIO T CTU ATSU
OO7TDEFOCHWEINMENMMIRANEDIIGS CA
I R>>CEINSAATLI EINY ISO, CY UO
AL
AI HWHFAEDSCHTTHSHATDISTRIASH  N
HAD. A WG K ET ESNID A WE GEE AE
AURHAD N SHAVATA IL97H YAFSIASR
NOPON ,
LL H
AS
UNNCAGCORYMA BE  HT N HAMEFUAGNT
TRKROEFLLRI
ON IIGE,VE
T D
E,MITO BBLNOE SE EINLI HSIBY
YRD THR IL'MENARTHUNLERRLY HOLI
CENTD.RSERCO. WRAURRSS
A
R LEY ?E N T
PT
INE TH
LL W TS HANOENEDFOWH